[Music]
life is weird we all know that but there
are some moments that weird doesn't
begin to describe sometimes it's like we
are seeing double the only thing that
can describe these instances is a glitch
in the matrix of the world wait until
you see what happens when a cat met his
doppelganger don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up and subscribe to
our channel for more videos you won't be
able to get enough of today we've
rounded up ten times that there was a
glitch in the matrix twins and plaid
this man was casually out for a nice
dinner in his favorite pod shirt when he
discovered a man who looked just like
him eating a few rows away now as if it
wasn't weird enough the imposter was
also wearing the same exact shirt now
the odds of wearing the same thing as
another person are relatively low but
are raised if you live in the same city
and typically shop locally so the
matching shirts on their own aren't
inherently weird but if you look one row
behind our cameraman's doppelganger
you'll see that even the man in the next
booth is wearing the plaid shirt as well
if the chances of two people wearing the
same thing are low then imagine the
chances of it happening in a group of
three pretty much non-existent how did
the universe manage to get these three
strangers not only wearing the same
thing but sitting in the same position
in the same restaurant in three
consecutive rows honestly we are a
little creeped out by the whole thing we
hope that after this picture was snapped
they all got together and exchanged
numbers
after all it seems like they were meant
to be triple the van a minivan is a
pretty sensible car in fact it seems to
be the go-to choice for families the
Toyota Sienna alone was sold 137
thousand four hundred and ninety seven
times in the u.s. in 2015 so you can
imagine how big of a number we would get
if we added up the total sells of all
the brands of minivans in the country
astronomical that's why it's not too
uncommon to see a fellow minivan on the
road when you are driving one in fact
the site warrants nothing more than a
cursory nod of acknowledgement now when
you see a minivan that's the same make
and model as yours it's a little more
interesting but it is still not
something to raise an eyebrow about the
in this picture made the list is that
three minivans of the same make model
and color all somehow ended up lining up
one behind the other at a toll booth now
either they are all good friends who
just love to have the same things as
each other or there is a major glitch in
the system
and the universe is laughing at its own
joke couple color swap restaurants seem
to be the place for weird uncanny
doppelganger situations in this picture
we see two couples settling in for a
nice normal romantic dinner nothing
strange about that but when you look at
the photo you quickly see that it's not
the fact that the couples are out to eat
that strange it's that they appeared to
be the same couple with Reverse outfits
the man on the left is wearing a red
shirt and sitting across from a woman in
a green shirt one table over a man in
the green shirt sipped across from a
woman in a red shirt how uncanny is that
and what makes it even more strange is
that the man on the Left looks to be an
exact doppelganger of the man on the
right or vice versa
who can tell maybe the universe ran out
of couples so it just started copying
and pasting couples that already existed
what's even stranger is that the couples
in question don't even seem to have
noticed each other it's like they're
sitting in front of a mirror but never
look up to realize we met whoever took
this photo was seriously freaked out old
men in a row usually seen five old men
together would be adorable but in this
circumstance
it just seems plain weird this picture
taken on public transportation shows an
old man nonchalantly riding to his
destination in itself it's fine and how
you look up and see that there are four
other older men who look exactly like
him how strange is it that five men with
the same exact bald spot would not only
live in the same city but take the same
public transport and not only take the
same public transportation but sit all
in a row one bald spot after the next
it's remarkable really which is probably
why this person took a photo either that
or they wanted to convince themselves
they weren't seeing double or maybe
quintuple to be exact if anyone is
missing a set of quintuplet grandpa's we
know where you can find them this
picture is like deja vu times five the
other passengers were probably just as
weird
as we are but we can only hope that at
the next stop five cute little balding
grannies are waiting for their identical
husbands what would you have done if you
had seen this scene snap a photo or get
your eyes checked bus of identical
couples you've probably heard the
popular theory that the longer a couple
dates the more they look alike while
there is no definitive data that proves
that couples start to look alike over
time it's a commonly known adage so much
so that no one really looks twice at
couples who resemble each other but
there is no adage about couples who sit
near each other looking alike on this
bus ride three couples sat in a row on a
normal day it would be fine and dandy if
they didn't all look exactly alike the
three girls have the same blown out
blonde hairstyle with dark roots that
alone isn't so strange but when you pair
the matching hair with a matching black
leather jackets matching blue jeans and
white sneakers things start to get a
little creepy
the more you look at the photo the
stranger it gets if you look to the left
of each girl you see they are sitting
beside males who also look eerily
similar
each has brown hair and a very similar
jacket could this all be a coincidence
or all these people go into a look-alike
contest if so we think it's safe to say
they will probably get first place twin
women twins are everywhere in fact
around thirty two out of every 1,000
people is a twin that means you have a
point 32% chance of being a twin and an
even better chance of twins run in your
family so being a twin is pretty normal
in the grand scheme of things but what
if your twin is someone you don't know
this person will be called your
doppelganger there is only so much
genetic diversity to go around
according to Michael Sheehan who is the
assistant professor of Neurobiology at
Cornell University
if you shuffle that deck of cards so
many times at some point you get the
same hand dealt twice having a
doppelganger isn't even that strange
tons of people have them but most never
come face-to-face with theirs in this
picture not only do the two identical
persons come in contact with each other
but they are wearing the same exact
outfit the only thing that differs
between them is their purse size the
funny thing is they don't seem to have
noticed each other we wish we could have
been there to see
turn around and come face-to-face with
one another or maybe the universe
explodes when identical persons meet we
guess we'll never know
old men taking identical walks elderly
people tend to like to go on walks walks
are good for your bones and who doesn't
love a little fresh air
this man was taking a nice leisurely
stroll along the side of the road when
the matrix went through a major glitch
and recreated him a few meters back
that's what happened right I mean that's
the only explanation we could come up
with to explain why two identical old
men would be on the same walk at the
same time mere feet from each other what
are the chances we don't know for sure
but we can probably guess they were very
slim to make matters even be rear the
men were wearing the exact same hat
pants shirt and jacket so it's not just
that there are two old men walking this
man has literally been copied and pasted
on the sidewalk it looks like something
right out of Photoshop it can only be
explained by a glitch in the matrix they
even have identical canes that had to be
an accident of the universe either that
or we need to get our eyes checked tell
us what you think
are we tripping or is there some major
glitchyness going on here toilet-seat
inception trips to public bathrooms are
almost never fun the toilets are rarely
clean and sometimes you run the chance
of walking in on one that isn't flushed
but that's not what has us concerned
about this particular toilet no this
toilet seems normal at first glance but
once this person was done doing their
business they lifted up the seat to find
some sort of toilet inception there was
an identical toilet seat right under the
first what possible use could that serve
do some people prefer to toilet seats
why we need answers we can't think of
any use for a second toilet seat so our
only conclusion is that the matrix is
undergoing some strange glitches the
person using this toilet probably felt
some serious deja vu after lifting the
toilet seat what do you do if this
happens to you do you just use the
restroom as if there is one toilet seat
and everything is normal or do you leave
the restroom or do you just crouch in
the corner and wait for the matrix to
fix itself we aren't sure what we do but
we know one thing is for sure we would
definitely be waiting for neo to come
around the corner and clear this whole
thing up cat looking out the window cats
often sit by windows that's nothing new
in fact depending on your cat's
personality it may be their favorite
place to sit they're curious nature
pulls them to check out what's going on
outside even when they are resting
inside the house but windows cat went to
the window it seemed more like he was
sitting in front of some kind of reverse
mirror than a normal window at first
glance you think maybe the cat is
looking in a mirror but then you realize
even that doesn't make sense if the cat
was looking into a mirror his reflection
would be staring back at him and we
would see the reflection of the house as
well but the only thing repeated is the
cat and the cat is facing in the
opposite direction of what the mirror
image would reflect which begs the
question what is going on here are there
actually two identical cats living in
this home do they often sit in Merrion
positions or is this yet another time
that the universe has messed up and
shown the obvious errors in its matrix
if so we are just going to pretend like
we don't notice it no swallowing of red
pills will take place here
inception on the tube depending on which
tube you get on and the time of day you
can have completely different tube
experiences for instance if you're
riding in the off hours you might have a
nice peaceful ride if you ride during
rush hour you may find yourself fighting
for space or squeezing in between
businessmen on their afternoon commute
home both of those situations are to be
expected what is not expected is to sit
right in the middle of a matrix glitch
but that is exactly what happened to
this woman on her tube ride home she sat
in between two older women who were
clearly just replicas of this same
person from there completely matching
outfits - the glass is placed on their
heads just so there is no chance that
these women are there by coincidence
they even appear to be completing the
same crossword puzzle is this some kind
of strange joke how did this happen is
this straight out of the film and
perhaps the biggest question of all why
doesn't
woman in the center look concerned at
all doesn't she know she's in the middle
of the matrix judging by her posture we
would guess the answer is no that's it
for ten times there is a glitch in the
matrix be sure to share this with your
friends and if you spot any more
glitches be sure to tell us thanks for
watching
[Music]